dozenten der synthetischen droge crystal
meth werden jährlich in tschechien
produziert das sind 1000 millionen
einsteiger portionen a 100 milligramm
die hälfte davon geht nach deutschland
was passiert eigentlich immer nur dann
was wenn irgendwie gut auf der straße
liegt also wird irgendwo ein anschlag
geschieht dann ist die politik
wachgerüttelt und es passiert war ist
offenbar ist es so dass die
drogenkranken und drogentoten irgendwie
striche in der statistik zu sein scheint
die nachfrage scheint gewaltig zu sein
in den städten und auf dem land und auch
in den niederlanden wird jetzt crystal
meth gekocht entwickeln es gibt viele
symptome dass man insgesamt sagen muss
dass wir vor einer drogen schwämme
stehen
[Musik]
crystal meth oder pervitin ist
tschechiens national droge die
geschichte beginnt mit paddel gregor in
der tschechoslowakei der 70er jahre er
ist einer der tschechischen drogen
pioniere mit seinen freunden suchte er
nach dem drogenkrieg im sozialistischen
alltag die drogen die es im westen
europas gab waren im osten hinter dem
eisernen vorhang nicht zu kaufen
[Musik]
1969 ging im westen die ära der hippie
ist gerade zu ende
aber hierher kam alles erst mit zwei
jahren verspätung
deshalb hatten wir in der
tschechoslowakei gerade erst angefangen
und für psychotrope substanzen zu
interessieren und die die es im westen
gab die waren hier nicht zu bekommen
stattdessen haben wir damals alle
möglichen arznei hin und tabletten
genommen
dann entdeckte die clique pervitin und
das verfahren wie man den stoff zu hause
herstellt ja ich war dabei als wir
pervitin wiederentdeckt haben erfunden
habe ich das aber nicht das war der
japan ag
die deutschen haben das im zweiten
weltkrieg verwendet und auch die japaner
auch als medikament kam es zum einsatz
als panzer schokolade wurde das
aufputschmittel pervitin in der
deutschen wehrmacht an die frontsoldaten
verteilt müdigkeit hunger und angst
wurden betäubt eine leistungs droge die
sofort in die abhängigkeit führt
besonders einfach war das damals nicht
schon allein weil die sachen dafür
schwer zu kriegen raten aber mit ein
bisschen mühe hat das geklappt und wenn
dann jemand weiß wie es geht und wenn
man so ein paar grundlagen in chemie hat
da kriegt man das schon hin
auch und der häuslichen bedingungen wenn
man die richtige ausrüstung
vor der wende interessierte sich die
polizei im ostblock nicht für die
gefährliche freizeitbeschäftigung der
jugendlichen
man ließ gregor und seine freunde
einfach machen
wir haben das seit 1977 78 gekocht und
damals war das keine straftat wenn die
polizei also zu uns zur kontrolle
gekommen ist
die wohnung wo wir pervitin gekocht
haben dann haben die immer nur geschaut
ob da keine minderjährigen sind oder
gestohlene sachen oder seite und dann
hat die polizei immer gefragt was wir da
machen und wir haben gesagt noch kapitän
und die haben gesagt na gut aber zieht
keine jugendlichen ein bei den
experimenten explodierte sein labor
babbel gregor kam weg von der droge
viele seiner freunde von damals nicht
[Musik]
heute schaut die polizei in prag viel
genauer hin
[Musik]
vor allem das team von jakub friedrich
er ist tschechiens drogenfahnder nummer
eins
[Musik]
seit jahren mit seinem team im geschäft
unser größtes problem ist dass die droge
so einfach herzustellen
herwig ihn oder crystal wurde in
tschechien ursprünglich von klicken aus
der drogenszene gekocht in erster linie
für den eigenbedarf
doch in den 1990 er jahren drängen
vietnamesische banden auf den
drogenmarkt machen die droge zu einem
geschäft drücken sie auch über die
grenze nach deutschland
diese droge ist sehr stark diese droge
ist sehr sie ist viel billiger ist
kokain sie führt sofort in die
abhängigkeit ganz schnell und sie hat
eine zerstörerische wirkung auf die
konsumenten bei intravenöse anwendung
für den weg fast direkt in die
abhängigkeit in prag gebe es hunderte
kleiner christel kirchen erzählen martin
und rené fahnder der drogenpolizei bei
razzien wie diese haben sie keine angst
vor einer schießerei sondern vor den
nadeln der süchtigen
meistens sind die kleinen küchen in
abrisshäusern versteckt in lagerhallen
am stadtrand einfach ausgestattet
es sieht nach einem riesigen müllhaufen
aus doch dazwischen medikamente die
braucht man für die christen herstellung
dieser kinderleicht zu martin und jenny
und deswegen so gefährlich
die grundsubstanz der drogist euro
ephedrin dass es den vielen medikamenten
enthalten wie vielerorts auch frei
verkäuflich sind in tschechien werden
diese medikamente deswegen nicht mehr
ohne kontrolle abgegeben
aber die szene hat jetzt neue wege
gefunden die besorgen sich die
medikamente aus polen aus dem ausland
und immer mehr pervertieren geht dann
auch wieder das ausland sie sind in der
szene schon so gut wie zu hause und
eines bekommen auch sie immer wieder
erzählt gekocht wird zwar noch in
tschechien aber die tschechisch
vietnamesischen drogenbanden bekommen
konkurrenz aus übersee
unterwegs nach bayern
passau
die dominante harte droge hier christel
die lage ist krass um nicht zu sagen
dramatisch in den letzten monaten hat
sogar weggeputzt wie die fliegen
[Musik]
seit 20 jahren berät der drogenexperte
christel süchtige eine arbeit auf der
schattenseite der malerischen stadt
[Musik]
ich habe schon immer den eindruck dass
viele menschen glauben in niederbayern
ist die welt noch in ordnung aber gerade
weil man das glaubt kommt man auch viel
viel platz für illegale drogen
am anfang mit sehr viel darüber geredet
und alles geschrieben und gibt es geld
und zeit und nach einer gewissen zeit
ist dann ruhe und das führt dann auch zu
der falschen einschätzung ja wir haben
ja den richtigen griff gerade in
niederbayern haben wir eine
hervorragende verfügbarkeit wir kriegen
heroin wirklichen christa wir kriegen
keine bis wir kriegen alles was das herz
eines drogenkonsumenten begehrt in 2000
haben wir so um 45 anfang aktuell haben
wir 83 brüssel konsumenten 83 für eine
beratungsstelle die ungefähr 750
klienten hat im jahr
wir sagen hier sagen hier da muss man
immer darauf schauen kein größter
konsument kommt freiwillig in die ställe
und sagt jetzt bin ich doch lieber
großen problem jetzt kümmert ist im
griff
haider sondern jeder der herkommt kommt
weil er druck hat weil der staatsanwalt
sagt wendt und deswegen ist es nur die
spitze die spitze und was unter dieser
fläche dann ist der bauch der werte
riesig sein und voll mit normal
konsumenten
ein kostenloser mit ordentlichen job
christel schimmert wie ein bergkristall
der reiz sich wie gott nimmermüde
immersatt metall macht christel sofort
süchtig der körperliche verfall kann
herausgezögert werden jahrelang das
macht die droge alltags taube ich habe
mit zwölf das erste mal gekifft
dann kam speed mit 14 jahren mit
christel ging es dann relativ zügig
weiter für mich ist der konsum normal
ich kenne es nicht anders
konsum und arbeit das ist wie wenn ein
anderer seine brotzeit ist
ich bin zwischendrin auch wieder sauber
und mein chef weiß dass er weiß zwar
nicht dass ich es auch unter der
arbeitnehmer ist kein gegner aber auch
kein freund tolerierte
ich bringe eben meine leistung
jahrzehnte lang waren der klostergarten
und der an grenzen der zentrale
busbahnhof die umschlagplätze für drogen
gelegen im herzen von passau
2018 schritt der stadtrat ein seither
werden alle öffentlichen bereiche video
überwachen
küssel abhängige bleiben auch ohne
offenen konsum und handel präsent ob
jung oder alt es sind die unauffälligen
wenn der drogenbeauftragte vorbeischaut
kann er leicht ein viertel der passanten
grüßen nahm so nistet sich crystal meth
seit gut 20 jahren im bürgerlichen leben
ein
nur sechs kilometer westlich liegt eine
suchtklinik eine für frauen und mütter
manche stehen noch im beruf
versuchen ihre sucht mit einer therapie
in den griff zu bekommen um nicht
endgültig aus dem bürgerlichen leben zu
fall
das verheerende bei crystal meth ist
dass die menschen meistens etwa fünf bis
sieben jahre brauchen bis sie die
problematik erkennen diese viel
gerühmten christel gesichter die stellen
sich erst nach vielen vielen jahren ein
die frauen erscheinen äußerlich fit
innerlich hat sich der synthetische
stoffe aber in ihre seelen gefressen
vor 30 jahren wurden ihr alkohol heroin
oder tablettensüchtige behandelt heute
sind zwei drittel der gut 30
patientinnen christel krank
mütter die nach der entgiftung wieder
ein geregeltes familienleben erlernen
wollen
oft war die sorge der frauen um die
kleinen ein auslöser clean zu werden
zuvor bestimmten der job und der takt
der crystal dosen ihr leben und ein
schlechtes gewissen so eine gelernte
altenpflegerin die nicht erkannt werden
will
ich fühle mich schon ziemlich schlecht
gegenüber meinen kindern welches kind
möchte schon eine crystal abhängige mama
und der gedanke es könnte das jugendamt
vor der tür stehen und mir meine kinder
wegnehmen
der hat mich schon ziemlich zerfressen
ich war durcheinander und hektisch das
haben auch meine kinder gemerkt ich habe
zum beispiel viel gemalt
da sind meine kinder in den hintergrund
gerückt sie durften meine stifte nicht
nehmen so blöd wie das klingt gerade
meine große tochter ist jetzt schon ein
paar mal zu mir gekommen und hat gesagt
mama jetzt ist es so viel schöner viel
liebevoller meine große tochter merkt
schon dass es jetzt anders ist als
vorher
das bestärkt mich weiterzumachen
ein drittel der patientinnen schafft den
absprung ein drittel schwankt das letzte
drittel stürzt ab verzeichnet die klinik
statistik und dass es jeden treffen kann
bei frauen ist die problematik
mutterrolle hausfrau rolle
alle rollen müssen zu 120 prozent
erfüllt werden
wir haben patientinnen die 30 jahre lang
kreuzbraven mütter und hausfrauen waren
und plötzlich auf irgendwelchen absurden
lebenswegen zum ersten summen kommen
über mehr als 800 kilometer erstreckt
sich die tschechisch deutsche grenze an
bayern und sachsen entlang
seit 2007 gibt es keine grenzkontrollen
mehr damals ein weiterer schub für den
absatz von tschechischen crystal meth
und einer für die therapeutin
wenn sie für fünf euro wir hatten acht
stunden lang dauern und trieb sich
besorgen konnten das stativ der preis
von crystal meth seither um das fast 20
fache gestiegen
also auch die nachfrage nach der
synthetischen droge
die damalige änderung der gesetzgebung
der tschechischen republik das bis zu
zwei gramm methamphetamin das heißt
mindestens 20 konsumeinheiten keine
straftat darstellt hat sicherlich dazu
geführt dass organisierte kriminalität
dort massiv angestiegen sind mit
verheerenden langzeitfolgen das
methamphetamin wird in die zellen
aufgenommen
es wird dort für dopamin gehalten es
wird dort vom stoffwechsel zerstört und
dabei bleiben beete radikale übrig und
die zerstören dann die mitochondrien die
kraftwerke der zelle und die
nervenzellen sterben letztendlich vom
ende jahr selbst in lohn und brot stehen
die konsumenten verlieren ihre sozialen
beziehungen zum schluss dran zu glauben
was heißt einzelgänger
es sind halt nur keine freunde die man
hat das sind nur bekanntschaften und man
ist nie bei den gleichen leuten weil
immer wieder etwas passiert einer mit
hochgenommen dann kommen die einen auf
therapie und die anderen werden
eingesperrt
100 milligramm ist die einstiegs dosis
mit den monaten und jahren steigert sie
sich rapide
damit der 20 jährige niederbayer der
unerkannt bleiben will
lang mittlerweile kräftig zu um sich zu
pushen
[Musik]
ich glaube das sind schon über den tag
das ist schon ordentlich er glaubt die
sucht im griff zu haben doch auch er
merkt der körper macht diesen trip nicht
ewig mit
ich hab mal ein halbes jahr pause gaben
aktuell bin ich auch wieder sauber ich
kann das vom kopf her steuern
ich fühle mich sauber eigentlich genauso
wie wir nicht drauf bin und dass ich
wenn ich drauf bin nicht schlafen muss
liebers kurz und lustig als langweilig
auf gewisse anzeichen die der körper von
sich gibt 80 aber schon operiert oder
wenn der kiefer ist verkrampfen anfängt
und ich trinke am tag so zwischen
viereinhalb und 6 liter auch deshalb
weil ich am tag zwischen 50 und 80
kilometer mit dem fahrrad unterwegs sind
aber wenn ich wieder so drei wochen lang
konsumieren dann geht es der gab dann
fange ich ja nichts mehr zu spüren
das ist dann einfach so dass man nur da
sind sich nur nicht erwischen
[Musik]
die oberfeld nördlich von niederbayern
verfügt über einen rund 100 kilometer
langen abschnitt der grünen grenze zu
tschechien eine region mit vielen
naturschutzgebieten kleinstädten und
dörfern
schon bald nachdem der eiserne vorhang
fiel verdrängte das billige und
hochpotente christel andere drogen wie
haschisch und heroin in orten wie
marburg das nie von einer harten drogen
szene betroffen war wurden die ärzte
plötzlich mit einer neuen diskrete art
des drogenkonsums konfrontiert
wir haben kein so genanntes
glasscherbenviertel wir haben alle
weiterbildenden schulen am ort wir haben
einrichtungen des gesundheitswesens
freizeitangebot ist gut wenn wir sagen
so ab ersten herzinfarkt ist es das
paradies
allerdings muss man zugeben immer kann
auf dem schulhof eigentlich alles kaufen
wir haben ja ein gymnasium man hört dass
man da sich alles beschaffen kann wir
haben eine realschule
da scheint es auch möglich zu sagen was
ich von den patienten höhere ist es
wirklich so dass die leute die rituelle
drogen benutzer sind ihre treffpunkte
ausmachen wird telefonischen date
verabredet und dann trifft man sich wo
auch immer würde mal sagen er kirche als
disco experten schätzen dass weit mehr
als die hälfte der jugendlichen heute
mit amphetamin und metamphetamin also
mit speed und nahe tschechien vor allem
mit crystal meth ihre drogenkarriere
beginnen mit party und leistungs drogen
nicht mit solchen zum abhängen
innerhalb von zehn jahren hat sich das
große christel angebot auf dem land
einen passenden kundenkreis geschaffen
die geschäftszeiten haben an manchen
orten einen bedrohlichen charakter
angenommen wie eine mutter dreier söhne
die nicht erkannt werden möchte
feststellt
oft höre ich den satz wir sind nicht in
amerika nein nein das was freunde von
dem mittleren sohn erzählt haben die
sich auch mir anvertraut haben ist es
tatsächlich so dass sie auch teilweise
morddrohungen bekommen haben
es wird immer mehr mit mafiösen
strukturen umgegangen einzel dealer die
den stoff auf tschechischen märkten
kaufen sind die eine seite des
lukrativen geschäfts ihr gewinn in
deutschland 60 bis 100 euro programm auf
der anderen seite stehen kriminell
organisierte banden sie kontrollieren
die masse des illegalen stoffe leben in
den zentren der region zum beispiel in
regensburg erzählt ein anonymer
informant
das hat kontur an genau um ein paar
leute haben das sagen steuern das
netzwerk das ist in festen händen
international organisiert hauptsächlich
russen und albaner mischen mit und
etliche türken crystal meth speed
ziemlich aus der szene verdrängt
vielleicht doch fünf prozent vom
normalen amphetamin speed kursieren rum
klar kennt man sich am berg bis nach
deggendorf runter da gehen schon kilos
über gebiete die ganzen ostbayerischen
raum nicht dass die daten und tätig
wären
2007 im jahr als die schlagbäume vielen
wurde auf beiden seiten der deutsch
tschechischen grenze das gemeinsame
polizei und zoll zentrum petrova
schwandorf eingerichtet die offiziellen
polizeistatistik der oberpfalz weist
seitdem einen rückgang der crystal
aufgriffe aus für insider aber nur ein
zeichen dass sich die vertriebswege
verschieben der vietnamesen markt an der
grenze hat als umschlagplatz ausgebuht
die habe ich auch nicht dass sofort
seine insel der seligen ist aber ich
würde mir tatsächlich den objektiven
blick wünschen eben über die auf vesta
aber festzustellen wirklich wie groß ist
das problem definitiv in haushalts
abwässern lassen sich christel spuren
feststellen sichere hinweise darauf wie
hoch der reale konsum ist und auf die
drogen küchen lässt sich druck machen
indem man den zugang zu den zutaten
beschränkt und überwacht und wenn
christus ist der ausgangsstoff eben in
der regel medikament bis dann sozusagen
missbraucht wir zur christel herstellung
und wen europa hier möglichst effizient
zb grundstoff überwachung betreibt dann
sind wir natürlich am ende des tages
auch effektiver den markt vor einer
überschwemmung mit der oper zu bewahren
crystal meth ein komplexes problem dass
schleierfahnder in den ämtern und vor
ort allein nicht lösen können die
grenzübergänge stehen tag und nacht
unter beobachtung
der erfolg der geschulten und erfahrenen
beamten hängt von recherchen tipps und
ihrem gespür ab und natürlich vom glück
und zu fällen
ein ehemaliger fahnder des sächsischen
landeskriminalamtes resümierte bei einem
fund von 300 gramm crystal an der grenze
geht man davon aus dass 15 kilogramm ins
land gelangt sind und immer noch werden
hunderte kilogramm im tschechischen
labors hergestellt
die amtliche statistik 2009 10
verzeichnet sie eine sicherstellung von
elf kilogramm in ganz bayern
die diskrepanz ist groß
drogenkriminalität ist kontroll
kriminalität meint je mehr beamte zur
verfügung stehen und damit intensiver
gefahndet werden kann desto mehr kommt
ans tageslicht
nürnberg im zentrum bayerns über die
autobahn sind tschechien und die
niederlande das alte und das neue
crystal zentrum schnell zu erreichen
[Musik]
nürnberg ist zum glück so weit dass wir
sagen wir haben keine offene
rauschgiftszene aber müssen ehrlich
zugeben dass wir ab 2017 mit christel
wieder auf ein niveau sind nicht mehr so
hoch wie zu diesem halbzeiten 14 15 aber
doch auf ein niveau das wir uns direkt
hinter cannabisprodukten und diesen
neuen psychoaktiven substanzen auf
position drei und vier finden
ein statistisches niveau wir haben in
den letzten monaten auch
sicherstellungen im kilogramm was für
uns natürlich schon beim ist es ein
schöner erfolg ist aber man wird sehr
nachdenklich wenn man vielleicht hier
berücksichtigen müssen was sonst an uns
trotzdem noch vorbei geschleust wird
die dunkelziffer ist im rausch durch
bereich sehr hoch 2016 gab es im
ballungsraum von nürnberg einen rückgang
ein jahr später wurde dann wieder mehr
sichergestellt darunter größere einzel
mengen ein zeichen für organisierte
kriminalität und christel ist auf dem
vormarsch
er steht bei den synthetischen drogen
mit beschlagnahmten gut 160 tonnen
weltweit auf platz eins christel müsse
so einfach ein fester bestandteil und
hat sie einfacher zu etabliert und einen
erfahrungen die letzten wochen so dann
wird eben in der kroner zeit leben ist
die verfügbarkeit und die nachfrage
sogar mehr geworden und sehr problem ist
die verschiedene letztendlich aus den
niederlanden bis hier zu uns nach
nürnberg oder halt nach mittelfranken
führt
ob altes christel aus tschechien oder
neues aus den niederlanden die truppe
des mountain activity clubs ist im
drogensumpf entkommen
mit hilfe ihrer beratungsstelle die
crystal süchtigen nahmen an einer
alpenüberquerung teil
das trägt es sie gründeten ihren eigenen
boulder klappt ein erfolg für die
beratungsstelle
doch der leiter blickt äußerst skeptisch
in die zukunft
inzwischen ist der markt abgegrast
inzwischen auch von amerika beginnt sind
es riesen konzerne wie amazon google etc
die autoren beratung anbieten und wir
werden erleben dass wir demnächst
irgendwo ohne schiri drogen beraterin zu
hause stehen haben die den menschen gute
ratschläge in anführungszeichen gibt wo
hindern konzernen wie amazon steckt der
aldis rauslesen wird aus der serie was
diese guten menschen mitzuteilen haben
und das kommerziell umsetzt
der zug ist mehr oder weniger abgefahren
da kommen wir immer hinterher
und das sind so beispiele wo es
natürlich ein stück weit auch müßig ist
und vielleicht auch ärgerlich ist dass
man so wenig gehör hat dass man immer
nur als kostenfaktor wahrgenommen wird
von einfach vergisst dass es wichtig ist
den menschen der gesellschaft in seriöse
angebote zu machen
eine sichtbar sinnvolle therapie niemand
sieht den mitgliedern an dass sie
schwerst abhängig waren beim knast saßen
jetzt sind sie sogenannte peers männer
und frauen die süchtige aus der crystal
szene und raus in die natur locken
klettern statt drogen und
präventionsarbeit einer von ihnen
spricht jährlich mehr als 100 mal mit
schülern das gefährliche an drogen ist
ja dass die erst mal sehr gut
funktionieren wenn man jetzt die drogen
wegnimmt dann entsteht ein loch und wenn
man dieses loch nicht mit echten
natürlichen erlebnissen füllt dann
entsteht depression und aus dieser
depression ist es einfach nicht weit bis
zum nächsten konsum wieder also man muss
eben dieses gefühl dieses bock aufs
leben hervorrufen und das machen wir mit
unserem verein hat einfach eine
gemeinschaft von leuten wurde weiß man
kann sich darauf verlassen und das
möchte ich gerne anderen auch bieten
weil ich eben weiß wie frustrierend das
reguläre hilfssystem sein kann aber
leider das ist so dass das
bundesmodellprojekt spotting noch zwei
jahren finanzierung nicht mehr weiter
finanziert wurde und wir quasi seit 2000
diese lücken ehrenamtlich schließen und
die größte chance ist der gegenseitige
austausch von informationen
wenn wir alles immer tot schweigen da
macht jeder sein eigenes ding und
definitiv machen und sagen dass ein
künstler ist nicht von der bildfläche
verschwunden ganz im gegenteil
den fakten ins auge schauen bedarf an
hilfe gibt es reichlich das zeigen
städtische abwasser analysen in den
beiden nürnberger klärwerken werden
regelmäßig proben entnommen
nicht nur um die konzentration von
haushalts und industrie rückständen zu
ermitteln auch der drogenkonsum kann
wissenschaftlich nachgewiesen werden die
drogen analysen in abwässern sind teil
des seit 2011 aktiven eu netzwerks co in
bayern machen regelmäßig nur münchen und
nürnberg mit
denn die teilnahme am programm ist
freiwillig die ergebnisse hört nicht
jeder gerne die aktuelle probe aus
nürnberg zeigt dass der konsum dort seit
2017 um 30 prozent gestiegen ist
doch crystal ist nicht nur ein problem
der großstädte 250 kilometer
nordwestlich von nürnberg steht die
kläranlage von annaberg buchholz nach
der wende hat sich die sächsische
kleinstadt herausgeputzt
doch die grenznähe zu tschechien ist
spürbar 2018 nahm die 20.000 einwohner
stadt am abwasser projektteil die
veröffentlichten zahlen sorgten für
aufregung
danach wurde in der gemeinde pro kopf
und tag mehr crystal konsumiert als in
frankfurt oder hamburg
das erzgebirge ist ein transit weg von
tschechien nach chemnitz und dresden
da bleibt auch im erzgebirge christel
hängen es ist ein thema was uns noch
länger bewegen wird und es tut dem
erzgebirge nicht gut ich muss aber sagen
wir sind keine treppen hoch freut die
vorhandenen kommen und die tiere sind
schon irgendwo und ich betone dass meine
persönliche meinung habe man hier auch
wirklich richtig mal die ketten anlegen
werde dann wird so frühschoppen aber
haben wir noch polizist ich weiß es
nicht
gut hundert kilometer weiter östlich
liegt sachsens landeshauptstadt in einer
abteilung der universität werden die
proben aus deutschland für das
europäische abwasser projekt analysiert
die uhr fuhr die zeigt dass kokain und
die unsere spur zeigt das methamphetamin
crystal und von dem rückgang können wir
auf basis unserer ergebnisse nicht
ausgehen
crystal meth ist täglich im abwasser
nachweisbar nicht nur am wochenende
das besagt dass christel eine
alltagsdroge geworden ist
den wissenschaftlern verschafft die
arbeit freude aber wenig freunde
die städte wollen nicht gerne negative
schlagzeilen wenn ich sage ist eine
statik da ist ganz besonders viel
drogenkonsum und dann hört das natürlich
der der bürgermeister wird das ist da
nicht gerne ja das ist schon auch eine
frage des gegenseitigen vertrauens und
von behördlicher seite ist das interesse
generell nicht so großmann versucht
fördermittel zu beantragen und bekommt
die nicht es kann auch aus anderen
gründen sein aber wir hatten schon mal
ein projekt wo wir im grenznahen raum
untersuchen wollten
und das ist dann ja den bürokratischen
haken lenovo gescheitert und man muss
auch sagen da zeigen eigentlich die
beispiele von neuseeland und australien
das dass mit dem politischen willen wenn
der politische wille da ist auch möglich
ist solche programme flächendeckend
durchzusetzen und dass die länder für
sich auf den erkenntnisgewinn daraus
ziehen können
um eben prävention besser betreiben zu
können
[Musik]
die anfasser untersuchungen zeigen
christel konsumenten sind gut versorgt
selbst in zeiten der korona pandemie mit
wochenlang grenzschließung das melden
auch die drogenberater bayern thüringen
und sachsen zählen dabei weiterhin zu
den crystal hotspot
nur dass sich die produktionsstruktur
verändert und sich der einflussbereich
von crystal meth in der szene ausweiten
prag die tschechische hauptstadt die
tschechische drogenfahndung hat hier
ihre zentrale
[Musik]
rund 230 drogen küchen haben die beamten
in den letzten fünf jahren in tschechien
ausgerufen doch gesteigerter druck
verdrängt das problem nur an einen
anderen ort der drogenmarkt scheint
gehörig in bewegung geraten zu sein
die produktionsorte verlagern sich
nachhaltig das weiß auch der direktor
der behörde
nach jahrzehnten intensiver
fahndungsarbeit was sich verändert hat
sind die aktivitäten der großen
kriminellen gruppen die an tschechen
entstammen sie vor allem dem
vietnamesischen milieu und diese gruppen
verzichten zunehmend darauf bei und
große mengen herzustellen
wir beobachten dass heute den crystal
produktion von mengen mit mehr als 15 15
oder 20 kilogramm in anderen ländern
das beobachten auch die kollegen in
deutschland in dresden und leipzig
befassen sich zwei spezialeinheiten mit
drogendelikten die gemeinsame
ermittlungsgruppe rauschgift des
landeskriminalamtes und der zollfahndung
in ost und west sachsen die problematik
die gleiche wie bei einem grenzländer
tschechischen kollegen sagen immer dass
natürliches ungefähr zehn tonnen
produziert werden christen und die
tschechen selbst stellen aber bloß 100
km sicherung also das ist mal eine ganz
extreme diskrepanz und sehr ähnlich ist
gefällt ist dass bei uns auch wir
versuchen an dem eisberg zu kratzen
aber wir brauchen dort natürlich zeit
und manpower
der beamte ist seit beginn mit dabei vor
überraschungen aber auch nicht gefeit
es kristallisiert sich immer mehr heraus
dass tatsächlich ein neuer markt eine
neue quelle von christlich in holland
entsteht und erkenntnisse dass das
crystal nicht unbedingt nur für das
bundesland nordrhein westfalen bestimmt
sondern flächendeckend dann deutsche
großstädte belieferten sollte ich habe
keine erklärung dafür dass auf solch nur
vietnamesen die im grenznahen raum zu
bayern und tschechien produziert haben
teilweise ausgewandert sind und noch
wlan gedanken sind weil die tschechische
regierung auch politischer seitz druck
gemacht hat die andere geschichte ist
das auch
markt andere tätergruppierungen welt zu
mexiko und kolumbien mittlerweile in
diesem labor politisches christel
produzieren eine razzia der
tschechischen drogenpolizei immer wieder
wird eine crystal küche ausgehoben
viele sind es verteilt über das ganze
land doch die ganz große kugel wird
inzwischen anderswo geschont
erkundungsfahrt an die tschechische
grenze für friedrich gibt es klare
gründe dafür dass kriminelle
niederländer nischen auf dem crystal
markt füllen
die fahnder haben die daumenschrauben
bei christel produzenten und dealern
angezogen die berüchtigten grenznahen
vietnamesen märkte schrumpfen
[Musik]
mit kleidung und krims krams allein
lässt sich aber der gewohnte umsatz
nicht machen
der stand vom crystal verkauf doch mit
den niederländischen christel kirchen
und ihren mexikanischen partnern können
die vietnamesen nicht mithalten
das spüren auch friedrich und sein team
der preis ist niedriger weil die dort in
viel größerem umfang erstellen
es geht um hunderte von kilogramm um
tonnen dafür muss man absatz haben eine
nachfrage und die gibt es hier in
tschechien nicht in tschechien es
christel eine klasse strom aus den
lokalen szene kleine produzenten und um
die herum ein paar abnehmer aber es gibt
hier keinen absatz für hunderte oder
tausende keller
die niederländischen christel küchen
scheinen das möglich zu machen was die
tschechischen nicht schafften
ballungsräume in der mitte und im westen
deutschlands mit dem stoff zu fluten
bei der großproduktion von christel
hilft den niederländischen kirchen das
wissen und die unterstützung der
kartelle mexikanische drogenboss sind
schon öfters mit touristenvisa
eingereist
so wundert es nicht dass zwei drittel
der in deutschland beschlagnahmten
christel menge mittlerweile aus den
niederlanden stammt spielte mit die so
mächtig sind das wirklich viel getan
werden muss so wieder boden gut zu
machen
die niederlanden geht es international
nicht gut sie arbeiten jetzt an einer
besseren drogenpolitik das ist doch
meine überzeugung aber sie haben einen
enormen nachholbedarf und die
nachbarländer sind mit unserer
drogenbekämpfung nicht mehr so zufrieden
wie noch vor ein paar jahren
dass die behörden hier zögern darüber zu
sprechen das kann ich verstehen
anfragen bei der niederländischen
polizei bleiben oft einfach
unbeantwortet vielleicht auch deshalb
weil die bedingungen für
drogenkriminelle immer noch paradies
sind ermittler uns helfen die story ist
unser land hat eine geschichte mit
synthetischen drogen in den 70er jahren
haben wir mit amphetaminen begonnen und
dann mit ecstasy weitergemacht
jetzt stellen sich die pillen bauer
mühelos auf crystal metro weil es viel
mehr bringt in zusammenarbeit mit dem
mexikanischen kartellen
das hat auch einen geografischen aspekt
rohstoffe werden benötigt es gibt zwei
hälften in der nähe antwerpen und
rotterdam
von da aus zieht europa offen und das
hätten die mexikaner gerne als ihren
markt und schließlich sind die strafen
lächerlich wenn sie geschnappt werden
gehen sie für ein paar jahre ins
gefängnis und das war's dann
das alles zusammen macht unser land für
die produktion von crystal meth
jährlich rund 20 milliarden euro spülen
synthetische drogen hier in kriminelle
kasten bei christel erhöht sich die
gewinnspanne da die mexikaner die
grundstoffe aus china einführen bereits
niederländische realität auftragsmorde
sprengstoffanschläge auf die presse zu
folterkammern umgebaute container und
drogen labor in scheunen im mai 2020
schlug die polizei wieder zu
der fund chemikalien- und christel mit
einem handels wert von zehn millionen
euro das größte labor befand sich auf
einem hof mitten auf dem flachen land im
achter damned einem dorf nur 20
kilometer entfernt von der deutschen
grenze
unter den festgenommenen ein mexikaner
ein kolumbianer und ein amerikaner
die bande mit der perfekten tarnung flog
nur auf weil niederländische ermittler
länderübergreifend zusammengearbeitet
hatten und mit verschwiegenen kundschaft
an einer schlagkräftigen spezialeinheit
mit besten technischen know how
[Musik]
die polizei wäre eigentlich nicht in der
lage gewesen die großen labore zu finden
ohne eine sehr umfangreiche
untersuchungen die in den letzten
monaten stattgefunden hat
verschlüsselungs telefone wurden
geknackt so dass die polizei in
frankreich deutschland und den
niederlanden monatelang kriminelle
abhören und alle gespräche verfolgen
könnte um so automatisch woche punktuell
gibt es bewegung in der europäischen
arbeiter fahnder ein signal für eine
neue drogen politik die wesentlichen
debatten diese in den wahlprogrammen
finden und ich haben in den letzten
jahren alle wahlprogramme durchgelesen
die finden sie zum thema cannabis das
scheint irgendwie ein sexy thema in der
politischen diskussion zu sein
es liefert keine einzige antwort auf die
wirklich viel schlimmeren probleme die
wir mit crystal meth und anderen harten
drogen haben lasst uns hinschauen nicht
wegschauen lasst uns es ansprechen und
vor allem lasst uns die leute dort
abholen wo wir wo sie stehen und ich bin
ein absoluter verfechter der prävention
diese drogen sind eigentlich nicht
gemacht für uns menschen sind zu krass
in ihrer wirkung und von daher dürfen
wir solche themen nicht totschweigen
oder irgendwie zu decken und sagen das
passt schon
es passt nicht das genial für jahr viele
menschen mit dieser problematik gegen
die wand familien zerbrechen berufe
gehen den bach runter
menschen verlieren ihren halt menschen
gehen kaputt land nimmt psychiatrien
menschen starben damit amphetaminen es
ist ein thema
zum abschluss unserer reise auf den
spuren von christel kehren wir noch
einmal zurück nach prag zurück zu dem
tschechischen drogen pionier pavel
gregor bei ihm begann in den 70er jahren
die wiederentdeckung von pervitin für
die drogenszene
gregor ist von der droge losgekommen vom
junkie wurde er zum sozialarbeiter
kümmert sich um drogenabhängige
berichtet von seinen erfahrungen
die formel für pervitin verrat er bis
heute zeigen will er sie nicht zu viel
unheil habe sie gebracht
das waren meine freunde aus den 70er
jahren
die meisten von ihnen leben schon nicht
mehr sie habe ihre experimente mit
drogen ihr leben nicht mehr die
kontrolle gehabt
was scheinbar harmlos in der heimischen
küche anfing war bald nicht mehr zu
kontrollieren
wir sind damals auf kritik stoßen ist
das auslassen und keiner hat uns gewarnt
wie gefährlich ein fehler dem paddel
gregor nicht wiederholen will
auch und gerade weil der geist den auch
er aus der flasche gelassen hat schon
längst ganz europa heimsucht
[Musik]